Michael mle joins us right now the Texas
Republican working in concert here's the
concept of fair and balance and being
bipartisan Henry qu the Texas Democrat
both kind enough to join us gentlemen we
have a lot to get into including what
you've been trying to do on the border
and meeting with a foreign minister of
Mex Etc but I did want to first talk
about this Prospect of of a shutdown and
to you chairman mccole it it seems like
that's inevitable the only thing in
doubt is how long it might last what do
you
think well I think that's right you know
Neil I've seen this movie many times
before uh it doesn't end so well
shutdown never uh I think benefits the
American people or our service members
who get their pay docked uh the members
on the border CBP border patrol agents
um I hope we can get this resolved uh
without a long-term shutdown um but you
know at the end of the day um we get
this done in a bipartison fashion
um and you know you just can't get
everything you want uh just one side of
the aisle and so I think you're going to
see a senate version coming back to the
house um and we'll see where this goes
um but again uh another Point Neil is
that they always blame Republicans for
shutdowns and and politically I don't
see this really working well for my
party either uh if they don't see that
we can
govern so on that point it's going to
stick to the Republican kind argu here
that it is four or five who are making
it very difficult to to wrap this up uh
and all it takes is one of them uh
disenchanted but Kevin McCarthy and how
he's handling this to boot him out what
do you think of
that well I think that would just create
more
dysfunction uh a lack of leadership if
we asked Kevin McCarthy as Speaker uh
then we go into speaker uh elections um
you know Kevin has uh been able to
surprise everybody against the odds and
get things done we have a conference
right after this interview where we're
going to talk about the path moving
forward so I hope uh we can work
together as a team and not be divided
when we're united we win when we're
divided we lose and this this CR had a
lot of border security provisions on it
uh that I uh personally thought were
very good came out the homeland security
committee included included my remain in
Mexico policy which cut down on these
political Asylum claims and quite
frankly shut the spet off to Illegal
immigration and yet you had 21
Republicans voting against it uh we'll
see where that goes Congress and qu are
on that issue I know both of you had a
chance to meet with the foreign minister
of Mexico went to the Border went to
assess the the situation now you've
heard from a number of your colleagues
congressmen uh who said that there is no
crisis at the border uh and it's not as
bad as it's been portrayed how do you
feel about
that well I live on the border I don't
just go visit for a few minutes we do
have a immigration crisis uh crisis uh
security it's a different thing uh the
border is secure when we talk about
crime statistics but when we talk about
immigration yes we do have a problem and
I've always said I think Michael McCall
and I are on the same page that if you
go play I didn't understand that when
you say secure secure to me means people
can't come through like a Civ secure
like safety if you look at murder rape
assaults use of the latest um Federal
officials uh numbers you will see that
uh Laredo for example is about two three
times safer than Washington DC the
murder rate here is higher I understand
that but that's not I guess your
definition security and mine are are Tad
different I don't want to argue
semantics with the sir but I mean it's
it's deemed dangerous and out of control
whatever your thoughts on that I'm just
wondering did your meeting with the
foreign
Minister give you some common ground
that you guys you know found that looks
encouraging or
not yeah and let me just finish my
thought uh it crime crime statistics
they're lower On the Border immigration
yes we do have a problem and I I'm I'm
in agreement we do have a problem with
immigration what we did was talk Michael
McCall and I as the co-chair of the US
Mexico interparliamentary group what we
want to do is to make sure that we push
security and immigration policy
outside the one yard line called the US
Mexico border if we can do it on their
20 yd line it's going to work a lot
better and that's what we want to do is
to stop people before they get to the US
border otherwise it's going to be very
difficult so let's let's do the work
outside in the southern part of of
Mexico Guatemala let's work with Panama
let's work with uh Colombia but let's
secure those area so people don't come
over to our US border now both of you
are more familiar with what's happening
in the border than many people who are
not even near it but the rap you hear
about Mexico I don't know about the
foreign minister but much has been said
the president that um you know the
soldiers might be there Mexican soldiers
might be at the border but they're just
watching those migrants flooding into
our country and don't do anything uh
chairman mle I'm wondering is that the
real
problem yeah I think Mexico is not fully
cooperating to help secure our border I
think Henry's right we need to push the
Border out and not at the one yard line
at our on our goal line but push this
thing out yeah I thought the prior
administration had this right by uh
stopping all these people coming into
the United States by adjudicating their
political Asylum claims in Mexico that's
what I brought up with the foreign
minister can we process these migrants
in Mexico rather than in the United
States because Neils you know once they
touch base then catch and release comes
into play that's why we have over is
that on Mexico chairman is I want to
raise the same point is that on Mexico
we're not doing enough to force that on
Mexico some candidates like Nikki haly
have advised maybe you just freeze all
Aid uh to Mexico all transactions with
Mexico because of this until they
change well that was a provision I had
uh in in hr2 the board security Bill we
passed a foreign uh operations Bill uh
where I did just that it refunds the
secretary's salary until he he puts
remain in Mexico back in place you we'll
see if that gets through the Senate but
Mexico has a responsibility here got it
real quickly Congress and your point on
that and do you trust
Mexico well look let's look at 2015 and
2019 President Obama and president Trump
why did the numbers go down in 2015 and
2019 the main reason they went down was
because Mexico was actually using using
their military Folks at their southern
border and they were stopping people
before they came in so there is a way
like Michael Mcall and I are saying
there's a way that we can get Mexico to
do more it happened under President
Obama 2015 it happened under President
Trump 2019 we can do it now but we got
to get Mexico do its job at that
southern border gentlemen I want to
thank you both and you're a shining
example of what it's like to work
together whatever party differences that
that is still possible um so that's very
encouraging I want to thank you both
have a safe weekend hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else